what happens when you're in a jammed
subway car and you're right up against
somebody else wash my hands a second I
get out that's it take a shower when I
get home and wash my clothes they say
like you know it's more if you already
have the disease but at the same time
it's are my odds better if I have this
odd you know like if someone sneezes
next to me uncovered
[Music]
social distancing is keeping enough
distance between you and another person
and the idea behind that is the only way
for a virus this particular virus to get
into the body it's it's not happening
just through the air you have to touch
something and get it into your face in
your body so if it gets on your arm
that's not going to do anything to you
at least that's what we're told and of
course this is all evolving
[Music]
so what can happen is if someone sneezes
and it gets on to you that can create a
problem if they're infected and at this
point we really don't know who's
infected and who's not because people
can be asymptomatic not have any of the
symptoms and yet be carrying the virus
and someone who is vulnerable could get
very sick so with that distance you're
just optimizing your ability to stay
healthy
[Music]
you know it's such an interesting
question because there are two ways to
look at it so one of the things that can
happen with this kind of panic about a
virus is xenophobia feeding into
groomers and having ideas that certain
groups are more at risk than others
whether that's true or not
so you layer on the term social
distancing and certain people can really
feel victimized by that or slighted but
as a therapist it's so interesting we
really rely on words and we're not
supposed to touch any patient that comes
into our office and what we say is put
all of your feelings into words so I see
a lot of people explaining why they're
not shaking hands or why they're not
hugging I mean I'm a hugger
you know I hug people like I have to
hold myself back but it's putting into
words hey you know I'm not hugging I'm
not shaking hands because of what's
going on but I'm sending you love anyway
so there are ways to certainly minimize
the emotional distance while keeping
yourself safe and protected
the best way to combat against
out-of-control fear is the facts we need
to get the facts and we need to get them
from sources that are legitimate the
other thing is to take control where you
can take control you know ask yourself
what can I do under the circumstances
and engage in activities that are
optimistic but give you a sense of
control and having a sense that you can
be okay that there are possibilities out
there for you and just keeping things in
perspective the other thing that we can
do is self care that if we are getting
sleep and exercise and eating right and
being around supportive people and
keeping our mind healthy our body will
be healthy and more resilient as well
[Music]